des outrages depuis tout ce temps mais
le moulin gaillardin est toujours debout
malgré son grand âge
plus de 500 ans le 15e siècle une époque
faste pour la meunerie
c'était une époque où il y avait le
développement de l'agriculture a
commencé au 12e siècle mais ça et c'est
encore développer encore plus au 15e
donc ils font ce choix des moulins il
fallait des moulins moulin à vent moulin
à eau
essentiellement des moulins à vent dans
les plaines la meunerie avant ça
représente une période de 8 900 encore
man donc ce drame une valeur assez
importante quand même une fois passée la
révolution française
après c'était des propriétaires
c'étaient les meuniers qui sont devenus
propriétaires dont il ya eu 7 8 menu à
peu près sûr ce moulin là jusqu'en 1895
l'année où il s'arrête être fonctionner
définitivement l'état le département la
région la communauté de communes ont mis
la main au porte monnaie
mais pour atteindre les plus de deux
cent mille euros de financements
nécessaires à la remise en état du
moulin la mairie a dû faire appel à la
fondation du patrimoine
on a pris une souscription on a signé un
contrat avec eux à paris on arrive à
parler dont à 10000 euros
nous avons une prime de 10 mille euros
en fait il doubla somme ce qui est hyper
intéressant pour les collectivités comme
la nôtre la mairie s'est lancé à la
recherche de financeurs depuis 2001 et
il y a urgence le moulin se dégrade
rapidement
je sais pas si vous le sentez vous avez
une pente là c'est en fait on s'aperçoit
qu'il a pris 15 degrés indice 15 degrés
et d'entendre si on se laisse aller en
descend et globalement bastion fait rien
dans dix ans un tas de planches quoi
donc
et comme on a le devoir de s'en faire
des passeurs de patrimoine tout
simplement on a le devoir de restaurer
des choses pour la génération future
des réunions sont maintenant prévues
avec l'architecte des bâtiments de
france
aucune date n'est donc fixée pour le
début de cette rénovation du moulin